you know so the idea is that if English
is more of a Creole in Haitian Creole
then why reserve the term Creole to only
Creole languages right that's that's a
passive very valid question and and and
nowadays in Haiti and also in Mauritius
I don't know whether you're aware of
this debate in Mauritius people ask you
know white why do we call you know
Mauritian Creole Creole although you
just call it Mauritian why don't you
just call Asian Creole hey a Haitian and
so as a linguist might take when I'm
being asked that question is that well
the people who speak the language
most of them call it Creole so what is a
linguist to say no you won't call it
Haitian you see because we have a basic
principle in linguistics at least in you
know when you consider the center
linguistics it's supposed to be
descriptive not supposed to prescribe to
tell people no this is what you say we
supposed to be taught what we say I mean
I have a Avila anecdote when it comes to
the because people see that the time is
negative that the term Creole because
it's been used to refer to lesser
languages it's basically bit of it and
now as as someone but who has a question
so as someone but up since we know at
least we can claim that we have evidence
that hey image in terms of its
structures instead of its history might
be more of a Creole than Haitian Creole
so why you know the time curl then
doesn't make sense if you think of
Creole as a sexual term as but the party
is that so the word Creole means
different things different people right
so in Haiti is someone called a language
Creole they don't think of Bickerton we
don't care about because I don't even
know who begotten is I do not know who
my poetry is you don't know who you know
missing either or these other linguist
who said all these ugly things about it
about Creole languages I did not care is
that that's why they call the languages
and and they're happy with the time so
for them the term has changed meaning
the term means just this is my language
the same way with words like let's take
the word neg okay so this is the way
that actually you know
in Haiti we have this word [ __ ] now
what does it come from it comes from the
French okay Nick now the French neg you
can speak in a puppy you know
solicitation Creole this is French now
you can tell that well this is connected
to Negro right now in the movie that we
talked about many times I'm not a negro
you can see that the term negro can be
seen as having some negative rotation
it's not positive right but guess what
in Haiti the term neg is positive you
see like I can call you Michelle with
the neck down no you may well I wouldn't
see it well you might exactly my negro
right but it doesn't mean it is
something negative about calling someone
like if you leave it if you live in
Haiti yourself you know you're a white
person after a couple of years Maxwell
might call you neg you see you become
neg
and hear the term net just means person
you know human you're human you see so
in Haiti the term neg although it
derives from neg which can be perceived
as being negative it's become just now
that refers to human being in fact we
saw that in fact we'll go back to that
the Italian himself see that you know in
Haiti now at independence will all make
with all Negroes even if you have white
skin you know that's what 1805 right
deciding told alterations that legally
if we went in Haiti we independent we've
established of freedom of sovereignty if
you want is black
whether you white whether you polish
with since you live in Haiti you black
and that was actually quite forward
right it was postmodern he understood
that race was not biological that
marriage was a political concept you see
so from the same perspective and could
see well Creole in Haiti means language
it's my language so you know and indeed
there are groups like I'm on Facebook
there's a group called Creole Oh funny
you know Creole phony they claim that
you know we can look at them or Creoles
phony
you know fooled me right
so the route here is Creole and then
they use it's like Francophonie you know
this French linguistic cultural empires
well let's do our own and and and talk
about cool funny because we believe that
we from wishes from seashell from heaven
or from Martinique from Guadeloupe from
Gyan we all speak that language that we
call Creole and we share historical
concerns interests in common so let's
call this creates this clue for me that
will make us stronger actually
interestingly if you go to the web
Facebook page do that because we have
interesting recording so different like
God people from God blue people from
Martinique G Anne Marie she is speaking
the Creole they even have Christian to
be ha which is this famous French
politician we know from beyond you know
black woman raised from very eloquent
they had the Rick Ritter have speaking a
grannies Creole you know DNA you see and
then you can understand them you know
academic you know when I went to
Mauritius I could speak Creole in
Mauritius you see and people can
understand me I could understand
Mauritian speaking Creole so there is
some evidence to Criollo funny you know
that there is certain is the level of
mutual understanding yeah definitely
you're right you're right you know that
that is thanks to the French that we
have this solidarity right but you know
it's it's it's you know you can either
use it for your use it against you right
in this case you think well we have this
mutual common interest based on our
similar languages and let's call it
Californian s turn it into a critical
critical power you know it's very
idealistic but you know why not
describing it to like people but what
about within linguist like using a
tongue Creole like to classify like
languages originated stay the same
well no because now in science you can
redefine your terms right so this is
different so when you're doing science
you know it's like when you know so h2o
water for a chemist it's not water for
for a gardener right yes because I know
we'll use water to to to to sprinkle
flowers without thinking about this the
structure of water but if you chemist
the word water as it's a meaning for you
and you might want to define what you
mean by water in that case I think in
system in linguistics I think that you
can you can say well I'm going to use
Creole with that particular sense and
for me it's just you know I'm going to
point to these languages you know the
people call them Creoles who speak them
and I'm going to use the name that they
use but I'm not going to assume that it
means something similar for all Creole
languages